10 millions de touristes dont la moitié
sont des étrangers s'arrêtent chaque
année en ile de france pour y découvrir
châteaux musées ou monuments historiques
10 millions c'est un chiffre non
négligeable qui permet à la région de ne
pas avoir à rougir bien au contraire de
sa carte de visite au moment où se tient
la quatrième semaine mondiale du
tourisme et des voyages et ce à la porte
maillot
le dossier de notre journal est consacré
ce soir aux activités touristiques en
ile-de-france paris excepté nous
reparlerons de la capitale demain voici
donc l'ile-de-france touristique avec en
bonne place en très bonne place même au
hit parade des sites visités
le château de versailles une valeur sûre
pas de répit pour le château de
versailles les visiteurs tous les ans
s'y pressent par millions
le centre georges pompidou et la tour
eiffel excepté le château des yvelines
est bien le numéro un du tourisme
régional à vedettariat que versailles
partage tout juste avec un autre château
célèbre celui de fontainebleau
conséquence inattendue de ce succès les
touristes boudent un peu le reste de la
région
ces autres merveilles paradoxe le roi
soleil fait de l'ombre aux autres
endroits touristiques d'île de france
sauf erreur de ma part il ya plus de
2500 monuments classés ou inscrits à
l'inventaire des monuments historiques
la région est très très riches dirais
même sens paris/lille de france serait
une très grande région touristique avec
paris c'est la première alors que
certains grands châteaux grand monument
est une aura particulière heureusement
nous nous serons félicitons et seulement
nous essayons de profiter de cette aura
particulière pour amener les touristes y
viennent
attirés par ces grands monuments pour
les les amener à connaître un peu autour
à découvrir l'île de france d'arguments
c'est vrai la région n'en manquent pas
pourtant certains châteaux souffre d'une
curieuse désaffection de la part du
public
c'est vrai pour vaux-le-vicomte bécon ou
chance sur marne
on pourrait citer également et coin
maisons laffitte et beaucoup d'autres
ainsi la ville fortifiée de provins qui
reçoit peu de visiteurs peut être en
raison de sa position très excentrée à
ce patrimoine historique considérable
non seulement fait de châteaux ou
d'églises s'ajoute toute une palette de
musées certains étonnant si le musée du
jouet de poissy bénéficie d'une certaine
renommée
on oublie parfois que la région compte
plusieurs musées assez extraordinaire
comme celui de la photo à bièvres ou de
la machine à écrire à crosne dans
l'essonne pour promouvoir l'île de
france le comité régional de tourisme a
plusieurs projets en chantier
tout d'abord donné une image de marque
touristique à la région ce qu'elle n'a
pas encore à la différence d'autres
régions françaises dont le seul nom
évoque les vacances ensuite lancé de
grandes opérations en concertation avec
les élus de la région
les professionnels du tourisme et
l'appui logistique de certains services
publics tels que sncf ou ratp avec à
long terme pourquoi pas la mise en place
de circuits du genre forfait une semaine
tout compris
mais les responsables du tourisme
régional savent aussi que tous leurs
projets ne pourront se réaliser qu'à une
seule condition régler les problèmes
d'hébergement car dans ce créneau tout
ou presque reste à faire
pas de gîtes ruraux ni de table d'hôte
et pourtant certains villages s'y
prêterait caravaning insuffisant sans
parler de l'hôtellerie ou le milieu de
gamme et très modestes ces responsables
ont également à l'esprit une vérité
première leurs premiers clients ce ne
sont pas les provinciaux ni les
étrangers mais les habitants d'île de
france c'est à dire le tourisme de
week-end toute l'année à cet égard il
existe à l'heure actuelle quatre bases
de loisirs
huit autres sont en cours de réalisation
ou alors en projet